one of the critics actually that I once
met said yeah Tony's techniques they
were great for about a year and a half
and then they wore off what do you say
to that is no simple if you don't work
out you don't get a muscle right I
always tell people this is there's a
daily practice like grinding if you
don't do that if you get up and just
have no discipline whatsoever you get no
value of anything your diets don't work
when you don't do the next one is
doesn't work when you don't do them but
most people have some experiences that
they want to shift and once you shift
those things your whole life changes but
life is constant growth my life isn't
here because I went to one seminar one
time and my life is Viktor life I I work
out I train my mind a train my body
there becomes a lifestyle it's not just
like you're depending upon somebody else
I'm gonna have to become somebody's guru
I'm not here to give them a gift I'm
here than to open up their own gifts and
that's really what my wish has been
[Music]
you
[Music]